I would like to open this morning
sitting first of all Chairman's
announcement Stefan zambelli member of
the EP
group as of as a member as of date of
the 19th of October
2023 moving on now to this morning's
agenda please go
ahead thank you president just in
accordance with rule
154 and the president's right to convene
Parliament I move that it is incumbent
on the president to call upon the
Secretary General of the United Nations
Antonio Gutierrez to address this house
in relation to the recent bombing of
Gaza and his call for an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire in the Middle
East thank you
president
thank you madam I will of course refer
your request to the president of the
parliament so as to sure she's aware of
that coming back to today's agenda the
first item is a debate this morning on
the European citizens Initiative for
free
Europe the first speaker in the debate
is the author Mr
vitk
I apologize Madame President I'm not
used to speak that uh soon in the in the
debate but uh thank you very much for
the floor I will continue in
Slovak thank you for giving me the
floor honorable members this is the
fourth successful European citizens
initiative of 10 successful
initiatives this is the fourth dealing
with Animal Welfare it has been
overwhelmingly
successful Signature Collection was
closed 2.5 months early and over 1.5
million signatures were
collected as far as the petitions
committee is concerned we have to say
that this ECI tool is key to direct
democracy in a crossborder area it is an
instrument that gives citizens a strong
voice we need a proper response from the
Commission in that way the ECI would be
an essential tool of participatory
democracy so what are the main calls in
this ECI firstly breed end the breeding
and killing of animals for the sole
purpose of fur production and end the
placing on the EU Market of fur from
farm animals and any products containing
such fur the reasons are quite pragmatic
farming of fur farming is in St
contradiction to the animals nature it
is cruel there is a risk many
risks there is a real risk that many
diseases May spread coid 19 bird
flu and there are huge risks to
biodiversity I am pleased by the
following at the EU Council in June
member states also responded to this
European citizens initiative by calling
on the commission to ban fur farming
across the the entire EU 14 member
states have already banned fur farming
so far only one country in the world has
banned the sale of fur
Israel I believe that this initiative is
extremely important we call for a
legislative proposal from the
commission we hope that we will soon see
tangible steps taken by the
commission I want to believe
what Mrs fion said is that if it matters
to Europe it matters to us that should
not be empty
word thank you the next speaker on
behalf of the commission
commissioner honorable chair honorable
members for free Europe as was just
mentioned is the 10th successful
European citizens initiative since 2012
when this mechanism was introduced and
the fourth this year
to which the commission will respond it
is also the sixth initiative concerning
animals which shows the importance that
EU citizens attribute to Animal Welfare
over 1.5 million citizens supported this
initiative and this level of support was
collected within 10 months this shows
not only the dynamism of the European
citizens initiative as a tool but also
the commitment of so many engaged
citizens across our Union to campaign
for their ideas and make an impact in
the causes they
believe last week the European
Parliament organized a public hearing
where the initiative organizers
presented their objectives and engaged
in a fruitful debate with members of
this house through this initiative
citizens request the EU to prohibit the
keeping and killing of animals for f
produ
production and to prohibit the placing
of farmed animal fur on the EU Market
the commission gives High importance to
ideas submitted via European citizens
initiatives and I assure you that we
will examine these requests with the
greatest attention to date at least 16
member states have already banned for
farming either across the board or for
certain
species Animal Welfare is and will
remain a priority for the commission a
recent example of that is the adoption
in early 2023 of new rules governing the
transport of animals by sea we also
promote Animal Welfare via the EU
platform for Animal Welfare or the EU
reference centers for Animal Welfare
whose remit has been broadened We Carry
Out regular Audits and controls to
enforce existing EU Animal Welfare
legislation moreover the commission will
present by the end of this year a
proposal to revise the EU rules on the
protection of animals during transport
the commission takes all European
citizens initiatives very seriously for
us to prepare our response it will be
important to carefully assess all
aspects of the initiative's requests
based on solid scientific evidence and
an assessment of the economic social
environmental and legal aspects we're
also looking at for farming from a one
Health perspective and closely monitor
the SARS of two and high paath Aven
influenza risks in those
Farms the work of the European Food
Safety Authority and the European Center
for disease prevention and control is
crucial in this regard the views and
support of this this house are important
hence I welcome today's debate which
provides an important opportunity to
gather more insights on this initiative
I'm looking forward to hearing your
views thank
you thank you the next speaker Mr
y Madame President commissioner
colleagues as a active member of the
petitions committee I am of course
absolutely delighted whenever we have a
successful request for a European
citizens initiative as we can see with
1.5 million
signatures this
initiative certainly deserves to be
taken
seriously it was handed in recently on
the 12th of October we had a public
hearing under the aice of the petitions
committee together with the Agriculture
and consumer affairs
committee so we've already seen how
important this issue
is so in my speech today I would like to
point out that my position is of course
my own personal one or colored at least
by
that clearly this debate stays into the
area of General values within Society
the question as to whether we can rear
animals purely for reasons of producing
fur and those who are against that I can
support your position
so obviously seen globally these things
are often quite straightforward once we
start looking at details Things become
more
complicated so we might have similar
ideas with cattle rearing for example
nobody would suggest that we use the
skin of the cattle to produce leather
but we throw away the rest of the
animal so when it comes to fur
production that's the kind of issue
we're talking about so one of the
questions we do have to ask ourselves is
what can we do with what remains of the
body can we produce food for humans biog
gas I'm not
sure but clearly within the political
discussion we have to address those
aspects the whole idea of rearing
animals purely to produce fur is
something we should
reject having said that I look forward
very much to continue this debate within
the
house and I hope that we can find come
to a conclusion not have to keep going
back to this thank you very much the
next speaker Mr
seedle President ladies and uh
gentlemen this is an initiative
supported by 1.5 uh million people to
phase out this awful uh
practice so we're talking about um mink
and fox for example the conditions are
really uh unacceptable the cages are
tiny the animals can barely move they
cannot carry out their natural
behaviors there is infected uh wounds
cannibalism all sorts of uh horrible
aspects and this is just uh to create
luxury items and in 2023 this isn't
necessary at
all this is something that should be
banned and Europe should be uh taking
the first steps to do this thank
you thank you the next speaker Mr
yeps Madam chair
commissioner just uh keeping and killing
animals for Furs is unethical it is a an
issue of
humanism and uh people simply don't
don't admit such killing anymore but
this is an issue of uh Fair
competition and actually we can see that
during
coid we uh experienced a lot of risks
posed to People's Health as
well from
18 the worst invasive species in Europe
Europe are coming uh from uh fur
farming and there are huge
differences in legislation in different
EU
countries uh my country uh lattia has
banned Farm DL for farming and I am
supporting such a solution thank
you thank you the next speaker Miss
um thank you
president I am grateful to the
petitioners for Gathering 1.5 million
signatures civil society and
NGS achieved this we're
always taken a back by the response the
commission talks a good game about and
anal welfare but when it comes to taking
action all we hear is debate and words
we have rules on animal
transport
but animals livestock are not being
properly protected ethically this is not
right and there is no economic
justification
we need
to achieve this
goal there is no need for this fur and
the corpses are just thrown away thank
you
pres Madame President
commissioner I attended the public
hearing a few days ago in the European
Parliament in Brussels
I must say it was a quite small debate
with just 11
members and the fur industry didn't have
an opportunity to take part in this
debate because they weren't invited they
didn't have a chance either to respond
to attacks or defend their position and
this is the way you want to legislate in
this house I hope that we'll be able to
have a debate on the first sector based
on scientific evidence and drawing from
what actually happens in this Farms we
have to be able to counter statements
uh and affirmations which aren't based
on science but which are based on an an
ecological ideological approach we have
to Ure that we can establish Fair rules
and we have to do this on a scientific
basis we have to listen to experts on
animal
behavior those of you who have read the
independent program of Animal Welfare
which is drawn up by seven European you
uh seven European
universities has surveyed all the
profound around Europe more than 15,000
have been visited this data was then
analyzed by independent scienti
scientists and we should use this to
draw up independent legislation on all
domestic animals including food
animals why should we do this important
to ensure that in future when we produce
for in Europe it should be in line with
the strict regulation of all Us in fav
of if we don't do that the fur industry
will disappear and other countries will
replace European producers but in far
worse conditions thank you than you miss
Bruner facing a miserable life in cages
they animals are gassed they're
electrocuted and sometimes they're still
consci conscious it's an
Abomination and it's also a risk for
xotic diseases as well these animals uh
bred for their
fur contract diseases quite easily which
can then
mutate in August last year 120,000 mink
and fox had to be killed in Finland to
stop bird flu spreading which had been
passed on by wild birds
h5n1 is uh at risk of mutation of
combining with another virus so I would
ask the European commission to end the
breeding and um selling of um Fair on
European markets it will end animal
suffering in this
way and progressively phase out keeping
animals in cages and possibly um
avoiding new pandemic as well thank you
Miss
H thank you president if it matters to
Europeans it matters to Europe those
were the words uttered by commission
president feline last month but what are
those words worth if the European
commission does not honor its own pledge
to come forward with new and ambitious
Animal Welfare legislation what are
those words worth if this house does not
even go to the effort of adopting a
position on the fur industry despite the
fact that 1.5 million people called for
this industry to be banned in Europe
what are these words worth president the
fur
industry quite literally picks over
Corpus corpses Predators praying on mink
Fox and raccoon dogs who wish to play
hunt and swim but the cruel reality is
that they are robbed of that freedom
locked in small cages throughout their
lives pining away thousands uh stuffed
in together they cannot run free they
harm themselves barely eat miscarry
their own babies on account of
stress foxes are even fattened up to
produce more fur animals farmed for fur
are victims of a diseased system and end
their lives in the mo
cruestv
we hear that if we ban the fur industry
in Europe animals will suffer a worse
fate elsewhere in uh the world well I
don't understand
that I think we need to ban the import
of fur that is the response and how long
are we in Europe going to remain silent
while the fur industry notches up more
deaths animals don't deserve this
citizens don't want this and most an an
increasing part of the fashion industry
want to put an end to this do we wait
until the last country in Europe bans
the fur industry or will the commission
finally take the lead and ban the fur
industry in Europe you could use the
final year of your mandate to show that
you take citizens seriously come forward
with a
an initiative Banning the fur industry
production and import of fur in Europe
let us work together to ensure a fur
free
Europe thank you Miss
Ferrara thank you madam president the
time has come for us to bring an end to
this suffering inflicted on these
animals and cages whether they're wild
or domestic animals uh when they're
farmed for the simply for the purpose of
making money from their firm more than
1.5 million European citizens have
supported this appeal by signing this
European citizens Initiative for furree
Europe this type of rearing of animals
is in fundamental contradiction with the
basic rules of Animal Welfare it's not
ethical it's not safe nor is it
sustainable it can be highly dangerous
for public health and of course for uh
our local
biodiversity the fur industry has been
classified as one of the five biggest
polluters in
Europe some 20 states have already
adopted the urgency of of acting and
have introduced legislation to limit
production
of so so many citizens of Europe are
asking for this so I would call on the
European commission to come forward as
quickly as possible with the legislative
proposal so as to bring to an end this
Market which produces nothing more than
useless cruelty for Animals let's bring
an end to F the fur Market in
Europe
movich
then M ad adamovich is not with us in
that case the next speaker is Miss
caval
Sor dear colleagues the coid 19 uh
pandemic brought us a lot of uh
suffering but but it has Shone a light
on a uh sector that European citizens
are looking at now and we cannot allow
this to continue uh anymore this
citizens initiative
lists different uh factors reasons that
we cannot uh ignore so breeding animals
for their fair is unacceptable it goes
against Animal Welfare it is a risk to
Public Health it is a risk to the
environment the basic issue I want to
talk about is what is the added value
how does this contribute to the
well-being of
society breeding animals just for their
is something which is obsolete it
belongs in the
past it simply cannot be allowed to
occur in a society that says it respects
animals as one of its fundamental values
we have to end this uh Madness animals
are being treated as objects uh and its
vanity thank you miss
m dear commissioner dear chair I stand
was the citizens keeping and killing
animals for the purpose of fur
production and sale is cruel and
unnecessary each year around 37 million
animals are killed for this business not
only can Animal Welfare standards not be
respected on fur Farms but fur Farm is
also posing a public health threat fur
Farms act as reservoirs for diseases as
we have seen during the coid pandemic
because of pollution and invasive
species fur farming also directly
contributes through the decay of the
used biodiversity and ecosystem this is
why we need to keep fighting for a
coordinated face out of production of
sales and F for fur free Europe to
become an official EU policy for the
citizens for the animals for the
environment it is a shame also that the
majority of the members of this
Parliament have voted against a
resolution for free Europe ECI even
though more than a million of the you
citizens have called for a ban on fur
let's ban forur farming thank you
[Applause]
thank
you
Mr the Deb the debate on F free Europe
should be free from ideology and the
decision on the potential ban cannot be
taken under any pression or emotions the
EU it's over 450 million European
citizens definitely fur Farms should
stick to standards European and
international when it comes to animal
well-being and no animals should be kept
uh in cages and we should not inflict
any suffering in this process on animal
um that's why definitely we should boost
awareness of fair farm owners about this
I am definitely for regulations for such
farms at the European level horizontal
regulations for such Farms should be uh
D based on respective National
regulations take account of regional uh
regulations and the influence on the
local labor market going away from uh
fur farms uh gradually should be done uh
with appropriate compensation financial
compensation we should make sure that
owners of such Farms would have the
possibility to re train and go into a
different business thank you m
danzi thank you com president the
commission recently announced that it
doesn't intend to propose legislation
regarding Animal Welfare before the end
of this
period This is a betrayal of the
principles of the treaty it's also a
betrayal and a slap in the face for one
and a half million people who signed an
initiative calling for an end to fur
production Europe the raising of animals
fur production is
cruel it's completely unethical and it
represents a threat for biodiversity and
the
environment the fur
industry is listed amongst the five most
polluting industry emitting toxic Metals
into our
environment uh many member states have
already already adopted a total
ban hundreds of fashion houses have
refused to continue working with fur in
response to the ethic demands of their
cons of their customers what would it
take for Europe to support
this clearly we do need to harmonize the
internal Market let's put forward this
change to legislation and ensure that
our principles live up to the
aspirations of our
citizens uh Madam chair ladies and
gentlemen uh I'm grateful to be able to
speak in this debate because I think
it's very important today we are
discussing a possible ban on fur farms
in the European Union the facts are that
more than half of EU member states
already have this ban my country the
Czech Republic adopted this ban in 2017
and it's in force since
2019 I had the honor to be in that
discussion and promote this ban and it
has clearly shown that the public the
people want this ban they want animals
not to suffer Madame commissioner uh we
however need a total paneuropean ban and
in order to uh in order for it to make
sense it's necessary to ban fur farms in
uh the entire Union the arguments have
been said and they are clear uh uh to
have animals only for fur is unethical
and immoral animals are killed only so
that someone can wear something fancy
it's a thing that is UN indefensible in
the 21st century there is not a single
ethical argument for animals to be
tortured this way then there is another
argument from an expert point of view
the animals suffer in their cages
experts agree on this it's not true that
the animals don't care they don't mind
the public who
wants for for production to be banned uh
the numbers are clear 1 and half million
of people want this ban and 89% of
Europeans according to the EUR barometer
wants the union to improve Animal
Welfare thank
you thank you Mr
anger gra president thank you madam
president to directly participate in
European democracy and yet the
commission simply ignores this is the
10th successful citizens initiative and
Madame commissioner is the fourth one in
which so many citizens 1.5 million are
asking us to legislate on Animal Welfare
this time citizens are telling us that
as consumers they do not want 37 million
animals per year to to be simply born
and raised in cages to be killed in
order to get their Fair they are Electro
electrocuted to be stripped of their
fair this is unethical unsafe
unsustainable and simply despicable it
disrespects the wild animals behavioral
needs it risks both animal and human
health and also harms our
biodiversity we want a a fair free
Europe now we need to ban this unethical
Behavior by humans on animals as soon as
possible in Europe and citizens are
asking us to do this in this mandate
Madame commissioner not later on thank
you Miss
ruse thank you very much uh president as
my colleagues have said breeding animals
for fair is unacceptable having animals
in cages particularly um wild animals
which is goes completely against against
their behavior gassing them
electrocuting them just to create luxury
items that should not um be the case
anymore it is time to act at European
level to ban breeding animals for fur
and to ban the sale of products
containing fur this is the fourth time
since the start of the Mandate that we
are here once again to talk about a
Citizens initiative that talks about
Animal Welfare so I would like to ask h
a question what has come of the previous
European citizens initiative on the end
of uh cages for example the commissioner
had committed to facing this out by 2027
there was meant to be a legislative
proposal before the summer but it seems
to have been uh abandoned how can you
expect European citizens to trust in the
EU if the commission makes promises and
then its president simply abandons uh
that just a few months from the
elections thank
you thank you Mr
Vincent president dear commissioner dear
colleagues congratulations to the
organizers of the for free Europe
successful European citizens initiative
as standing reporter for the ECC in the
parliament I am glad that another
initiative made it to the plenary the
10th in 10 years more than 1 and a half
million Europeans signed your proposal
it is a remarkable number which means
not only a huge responsibility towards
the supporters but it gives a strong
signal to the you institutions that the
ecis cannot be ignored by the
legislators the EU animals welfare
legislation is currently under revision
the EP group welcomes it the
commission's initiative is an
opportunity to introduce the necessary
Provisions concerning a full ban on fur
Farms our Parliament is an important
supporter of citizens
participation uh through the plenary
debates we have PR raising awareness of
the many ideas that emerg from the
public agenda through various ecis in
these regards we will certainly
carefully assess the actions taken by
the commission on the first free EU
thank you very
much
gra thank you m
Nole honorable
members
commissioner it is clear that the people
have spoken the citizens initiative
adopted a clear
stance backing our position on Banning
fur
farming trading in fur for one coat
alone 60 mink have to be slaughtered
what about chinchilla
coats 200 animals have to be slaughtered
for that single Cod
that is
perverse it is Despicable that so many
animals have to be killed for
fashion breeding animals for fur
production alone is perverse we need to
be clear what uh our position is we
don't want fur production and we don't
want countries around the world to be
able to import their fur into Europe we
need a clear ban on Imports as well fur
production has no place in Europe thank
you Miss
Reaper animals can feel pain fear
happiness just like
animals they are described as sentient
beings under the EU treaties despite
this
animals every single day have have to uh
suffer millions of times over they have
short painful lives in these cages when
they are bred for fur and what is the
need for this we don't need fur there's
enough other
Alternatives and breeding animals in
this way can lead to different zunos as
well and uh fur production is bad for
the environment there are dangerous
chemicals that are used and it threatens
our native species
as well so fur is unethical bad for the
environment and the commission should uh
ban uh breeding for fur and selling a
fur on the European market over a
million citizens want this so thank you
very much um to this European C's
initiative we must follow up on this now
we have seen lots of uh initiatives on
Animal Welfare so we want to see the
corresponding legislation thank you
Canan thank you Miss
panan thank you for the makers of this
Initiative for their activism and for
the sign signatories for the strength
that they are presenting the views of
the people and our
citizens for farming is
unethical for
useless impr practical axis item for the
markets of Russia and China this spreads
diseases like Avan influenza it makes
use of food that could be processed for
human food it processes animals so that
they become ill and
they don't have no well-being wellbeing
and causes lifelong suffering in small
cages
and finally their life ends unethically
and very cruy it is time to go forward
forward for I hope that first of all
commission will put a ban on F fur
farming and brings about ban on cage
keeping and gets animal wellbeing
legislation that is
already in the working program of the
commission tomorrow should be better
than today thanks to the activism of our
citizen now it's our turn to
act thank you Mr
Miller Madame President Madame
commissioner ladies and gentlemen
undoubtedly Fair farming is very cruel
towards the an
animals uh we are keeping them in
impossible conditions and they lives are
ended in an inhumane way we cannot any
longer ignore the cruelty of the fair
farming sector it is also a serious risk
for public health the pollution is
immense um this is again a risk for our
health and our ecosystems we cannot also
ignore a very difficult situation of
people who live within proximity of fur
Farms we have to stop this inhumane uh
industry we should say yes to the Future
where uh we have Fair free world it's
high time the EP and the commissioner
reacted
Madame President fur farming is deeply
unethical all animals need to live in an
environment um that they that is natural
for them breeding animals in cages
causes diseases and
suffering the European citizens
initiatives F free Europe is asking to
ban fur farming in Europe this needs to
be banned because it's ethically and
environmentally untenable it is our time
to act F farming must be banned all over
Europe there are bans in place in many
EU countries and the EU needs to follow
this is not a profitable industry many
farms are suffering financially and the
uh pandemic has shown that this is a
problematic
industry first are popular only in
Russia and China it is important that we
ban fur farming and that we also help
the Professionals of this industry into
new
jobs however the commission has not
acted it is essential that we act upon
these extremely popular European
citizens initiatives and the commission
must show that they care about animal
welfare in Europe thank you go thank you
Mr
kassi thank you madam president more
than 1 and a half million European
citizens have mobilized to sign this
petition calling for an end to the
raising of animals for fur production in
Europe locking these animals up in small
Pages cages and producing them just for
fur is
unacceptable that's against the rules of
animal welfare and Concepts in our
treaties the time has come for put an
end to this cruel practice we have to
highlight the risks which come with this
production both for human and animal
health don't let forget what happened
during the pandemic when hundreds of fur
Farms had to be closed down after
viruses were being transmitted from
animals to humans 17 million animals
were killed in Denmark
alone I can still remember the shock I
felt seeing the pictures this is also
very important in terms of the EU policy
on one Health Human Animal environmental
health are all
linked the production of animals for fur
has already been banned in 18 member
states and I think the time really has
come for an initiative from the
commission it's important that we do our
best to protect our health and leave
animals with their
fur thank you m kassi moving on now to
catdi I have a series of names on the
list Mr ostriches first of all
thank you president colleagues first of
all I would like to thank all the
citizens of Europe who've signed the
petition and supported this very
important initiative no for free
Europe the initiative has a very
meaningful name and I am sure that the
European Union institutions have to
react quickly to the one and a half
million signatures of our citizens and
it has to come up with the reasonable
conclusion and decision Europe has
grown to make such decisions and this
cruelty cannot be justified I'm very
happy to announce that the Lithuania was
the most recent country which in October
adopted the decision to
ban for farming in Europe as of 2027
that's a very good example and finally
colleagues we shouldn't even call it a
ban because it's a limitation a
restriction for the benefit of public
interest thank
[Music]
you
Miss thank you president commissioner
all polls show how cruel fur production
is and it is rejected by virtually all
Europeans this is vital for animal
rights and for the millions of Europeans
who signed the petition for a furree
Europe we see daily atrocities in the
industry animals locked in cages injured
forced into cannibalism it is a barbaric
industry raking in profits through the
suffering of
animals bear in mind that uh natural fur
also has a far worse environmental
impact than synthetic fur this is a
crucial issue commissioner take it
seriously and come forward with a ban uh
on animal
fur M valis I'm sorry Mr Wallace
president for farming is deeply cruel
it's also bad for biodiversity mink is
an invasive species in Europe we want to
see a ban on for farming in the EU and
we want to see a ban on farm for
products but this should not be the
limit of our ambition in terms of Animal
Welfare reforms in the F the for
strategy the commission promised that it
would propose a revision of the eu's
animal welfare legislation by the end of
this year the commission revealed its
work program this week the proposal on
the transport of animals is the only one
of the four Animal Welfare regulations
the commission promised to revise that
is actually included the promised
proposal to transition to Cadre systems
is completely absent these broken
promises show a complete disregard not
only for animal welfare and well-be but
also for particip democracy for
sake let's get rid of for
farming thank
you m d gra Presidente every year
millions of animals are bred and killed
in the EU for four main species
obviously being mink foxes and raccoon
dogs and the whole idea is so utterly
repulsive and hard for so many citizens
to understand this is wanton cruelty
there is no basis for it whatsoever and
this initiative has massive support
across all member states for a European
ban on the farming and killing of
animals for fur now it is welcome that
over a dozen member state governments
representing about two-thirds of the
eu's population have backed the calls
for an
wide ban including our own uh Ireland
one of the more recent ones to join
despite many attempts that we made
during our time in the Irish parliament
in these Infamous fur Farms foxes are
kept in solitary confinement in battery
cages preventing them from natural
interactions prevented from running
digging exploring in wi in small cages
less than 1.2 M squares we've seen the
damage to them for is non-essential
there are animal free alternatives for
Foxx's sake it's time to ban the
practice thank
you turning back to the commissioner now
asking you to respond to the
debate thank you very much chair
honorable members I listened very
carefully to all your interventions as
we heard today animal farming for fur
production is a crucial topic that
attracts a high level of public of
Citizen interest and I thank you for
putting these important questions
related to it today's debate has
provided a useful input to the
commission's assessment of the citizens
initiatives requests together with last
week's public hearing it will help us to
formulate our conclusions in the
communication on the fur-free Europe
that we will adopt in December and to
reflect on the way forward on Animal
Welfare once again I thank you for your
views and ideas expressed
today thank you after this
intervention or that intervention brings
this debate to a close moving on to the
next item on the
agenda which is European protein
strategy the first speaker is the
rapporter miss
visner
yeah very very
POS dear o